if there's going to be a spin-off where
are we going I want to see
I would really love that God knows
Hollywood could use one of those
I mean hold up hold up
hold up
you look great thank you I mean I have
to start because she's standing right
behind you having Meadow in this film
Michelle as a nod to her daddy and just
cementing his legacy what that mean to
y'all yeah she's all grown up now man
it's crazy I was cradling her in my arms
she was like a little baby
yeah two thousand
wow time flies huh and you know Paul
would be so proud of her yeah he is he
is
how about this tonight ma'am you're
having a Premiere in front of the
Coliseum in Rome what are you doing what
are you doing I'm pinching myself that's
what I'm doing I'm pinching myself
because I mean how did they let us do
this
it's insane really how did they this was
a little street racing you're ever gonna
get that kind of like free pass I think
Rome's the play yeah you know what I
mean what what represents what
represents the other side of the tracks
what represents the street kids more
than the Coliseum I'm sure I mean these
guys basically they were they were
dragged here to fight fight their way
out back into society I mean it's kind
of reminds me of us in many ways okay
tell me this because I just got done
with Ben what's the most Vin Diesel
thing that you've ever seen Vin Diesel
do
that's a lot that's a loaded question
I've seen Vin Diesel do a lot of Vin
Diesel things that are very Vin Diesel
um you know what
you know what I think the tank top and
jeans to a Premiere is like my favorite
Vin Diesel thing that Vin Diesel does
that's true that's true
he's just like you know I he really he
really gets that the people just want
him and they don't care about the it's
interesting because you know it really
goes to the symbolism of like us
representing in a way the kids who came
in through the back door through the
kitchen of Hollywood we really would
never invited and people never expected
us to stay here this long you made your
own table you didn't have a seat at the
time we just kind of came in through the
kitchen and we were just like yo I'm
gonna sit at this table in front over
here by the stage and we're not going
anywhere by the way try to move me I
just try to move and I think that's what
the tank top and jeans represent
absolutely can we talk real quick about
Jason
um as the villain and the wild
dude he's a little cray-cray isn't he a
little little just a little I love his
confidence yeah I you know there's
something so sexy about a man who's so
confident in himself that he can
you know just wear whatever he wants and
do whatever he wants and it doesn't
matter how feminine it looks or It just
fits because he's so confident in his
masculinity that he could do that he's
just cruel man he's a pirate and he's
wild Pirates are welcome here even even
if they're mean and try to kill us there
you go okay even though the main kind of
event is coming to an end doesn't mean
that the stories have to be done so if
there's going to be a spin-off where are
we going what do you want to see what's
going to happen
what did you like to know you know you
know what I want to see though but
and
that's what I want to say I want to see
all y'all get down all of you I would
really love that God knows Hollywood
could use one of those we don't have any
good ones not really really good ones
they try to do it but it's it's like
when you do something in the name of a
girl movement it you're placating to an
audience that doesn't want to see that
like most franchise I see badass girls
go at each other naturally not not
because you think girls are hot right
now you know what I mean and the scripts
they're horrible they're written by some
guys who don't know anything about women
so like yeah we would if if we ever did
that we would definitely have to take it
to the moon because we have to do
everything that we've seen all everybody
do wrong in the industry when it comes
to women in action movies but don't you
think a lot of you all could do that
like what you got nobody better than me
Bree and Charlize are you kidding come
on now yeah I'm all playing it from your
lips to God's ears honey I heard it all
right Mama have a good one great
foreign